before we get started gonna give some
love to the sponsor of this video this
video is brought to you by factor factor
offers fresh never frozen meals and a
variety of options right to your door
the 34 plus Chef prepared dietitian
approved weekly options there's always
something new to try keto calorie smart
vegetarian vegan options Protein Plus no
prep No Mess ready in two minutes so you
can get back to eating while you're
binging this is very convenient for me
if you couldn't tell by now by my
unchanged intro song and background for
nearly 14 years now I'm a creature habit
what can I say an attempts to translate
to my eating habits I have a routine I
eat pretty much the same thing daily
look it works for me but it doesn't mean
I don't enjoy some new flavors and new
meals to flirt with the palette and the
fact that for me grocery shopping is on
the list of most unenjoyable things just
in life delivered fresh right to my door
that is just chef's kiss so go to
factor75.com or click the link below and
use code john's50 to get yourself 50 off
your first Factor box also I do have
fish for this review
God ironically mention that one
so the little mermaid is Disney's latest
attempt at taking an animated classic
and translating it to live action cherry
on top let's take the lovable sidekick
characters and make them look like what
Metallica was singing about and Enter
Sandman now funny post viewing
experience this because when I got out
of the movie I was like yeah that was
cute it was surprisingly enjoyable but
on my drive home when I was getting my
thoughts together for my video the
little nitpicks started they started to
stack because there are a lot of them
not gonna list them all in here but
there are some worth mentioning but I'm
gonna go ahead and list out what I liked
about this movie because I'm gonna give
you some sugar before this spice right
what I liked Halle Bailey I thought she
was great as Ariel she's sweet she's
endearing has that Curiosity albeit that
naive curiosity she's adorable and most
importantly has an amazing voice but
it's not just her Prince Eric Jonah
Howard King I believe I'm pronouncing
his name correctly I thought he was
great as well more so in here than the
anime because the animated movie is like
hey that's the pretty guy you got a kiss
in three days get at it this movie
actually did a good job at fleshing
Prince Eric out we talk about his hopes
and dreams we find out a little more
about him so I was glad to see that just
for him as a character but that also
really worked in me feeling their
connection and that's that's the heart
and soul of the movie this it's the
nucleus it's the core of the this entire
experience is the love between these two
characters the animated Little Mermaid
is a complete and total classic but you
got to admit by the end you kind of had
that feeling of like oh yeah they're
infatuated in that shotgun wedding at
the end of a weekend in Vegas kind of
way it's still three days in this movie
so it still happens fast but you still I
saw the Sparks there I got the chemistry
so when I say I have nitpicks for this
movie and they're there I absolutely
totally mean it but what I liked being
them in their chemistry that's a huge
part of the film so it's what brings the
movie Up does outweigh what brings the
movie down but what brings the movie
Down is there it's actually a perfect
embodiment of the phrase Death By A
Thousand Cuts I feel like anybody who
doesn't like this movie they they got
there by a Thousand Cuts a thousand
little nitpicks that just stacked up by
the end and it was too much I get it
I'll start with the more glaring things
and work my way down to what Jeremy's
just bitching I again not going to be
everything but the most glaring thing is
the fact that animation just has a style
and a punch to it it has a stylistic way
about it that I think the Little Mermaid
just lends itself to not that this movie
never looked animated there are some
moments Under the Sea looked about as
live action as that Mary Poppins penguin
segment but you do see that in the Under
the Sea musical segment man original
Under the Sea segment that was it was
like a cup of coffee in the morning that
got you going under the sea segment here
kind of gave me that feeling of that was
that was pretty good karaoke example in
this segment with Sebastian's listing
off the marine life that plays
instruments in the animation you see the
marine life playing the instruments
because why would you not in this
live-action version when he's listing
off the various marine life that plays
instruments you see these big sea
turtles walking it's just one long shot
to see turtles walking because why would
you not show sea turtles walking while
listing off marine life that plays
instruments makes sense it's like if the
animated Under the Sea felt like a cup
of coffee to get you going in the
morning this live action Under the Sea
kind of felt like taking a piss in the
morning it's not waking me up it's just
kind of it's routine we're just getting
through it to get to the next thing and
they seem like a little nitpick so maybe
they are but to me they're details that
change the world and the characters in
the world like Ursula not hiding the
fact that she says pathetic when she's
singing about people who come to her for
help pathetic and outwardly just saying
pathetic magic changes both Ursula and
Ariel Ursula because she's less crafty
and Ariel's a bit more of an idiot
because she wasn't like did you just
call people pathetic wait are you
calling me pathetic your weird little
skeleton dungeon in the bottom of the
sea was kind of a red flag but now I'm
leaving bye that's why I talk about a
few of these Thousand Cuts also in a
world of Disney playing it safe Ursula
doesn't turn mer people into the little
the little seaweed monsters anymore they
just die which I imagine for the
original animation it was Disney being
like we can't kill people we'll just
turn them into little seaweed slaves on
Ursula's bathroom floor because that's
less dark but no it's far worse I don't
even care what anyone says that scared
the piss out of me when I was a kid
actually I haven't even talked about
Melissa McCarthy as Ursula Melissa
McCarthy as Ursula was the thing I was
most concerned about in here because I
heard that I was like I feel like I know
what I'm getting I'm getting Melissa
McCarthy but she looks like Ursula but
she's still Melissa McCarthy being
Melissa McCarthy to her credit it 99 of
the time she was legit playing Ursula
she did not annoy me there was one scene
I can think of in particular where I was
like that was a Melissa McCarthy moment
it was a moment that just existed to
remind you that you're watching a family
comedy Now Ursula's I've always found
her funny but Sinister funny she does a
pretty good job at that but this one
scene I was like well that was just
Melissa McCarthy funny funny it felt out
of place it felt weird this wasn't in
the original but we're gonna put it in
here it's like but it feels shoehorned
and feels weird it feels out of place
like example the new musical segments in
here that were not in the original
they're made up for here but it feels
like it was made up it feels like music
that was made up over three decades
later that doesn't really fit with the
music in the movie there's a Synergy
with the musical score The Little
Mermaid musical segments it all works
together it works in tandem to create
some audible musical experience that
feels consistent and okay we have these
new songs that come in that don't feel
consistent doesn't feel like the same
world could have cut a couple of those
out could have saved yourself you know
10 15 minutes of this 50 minute longer
than the original run time it's 50
minutes longer did it need to be no to
its credit it does use some of that time
to flesh out Eric and you know like I
said before you feel that Chemistry
Between Eric and Ariel and that's part
of that extra time was it 50 minutes of
that not at all it didn't need to be 50
minutes longer it's about 50 minutes
anyway if you take end credits out of
the equation the fact that these end
credits are longer than the old end
credits probably 45. still fact remains
this movie felt like it was at war with
itself a few times just in terms of
timing and pacing within a scene it's
like they feel like they have to have
the dialogue in this scene from The
Animated original but it doesn't flow as
well weird thing is at the very end I
had heard this and I was like come on no
yep there's no wedding at the end I know
spoiler for the end but
you're
you know the story of Little Mermaid but
you know at the end of Little Mermaid
there's this wedding they have to stop
the wedding it's not a wedding in here
it's an engagement party and that just
feels different granted the real clock
you're up against is the sun you when
the Sun goes down we lose but a wedding
is such a stone wall that it works in
tandem with that concept of the sun
going down it really feels like zero
hour it's like this when the day ends we
lose we have to stop the wedding this
this forever bond that Eric's going to
enter that we just can't let him enter
and that's the bummer for this video
because I started the video off like oh
yeah I liked Ariel and Eric and I really
felt that chemistry I thought Halle
Bailey was great and listen yeah also
let me and nitpick about these
things but my nitpicks went on for so
much longer in the video some of them
are bigger than others absolutely but I
maintain the charm of what did work
seems so small but it is the core of the
film it's Ariel and Eric and if you can
stick that Landing you can have a sweet
enjoyable film for families that's just
covered by a lot of annoyances but I'll
say it's a good time no alcohol required
at matinee price a huge bummer that the
cook segment LEP was not in here what a
great segment from the animated Little
Mermaid and if you're really if you're
looking at it in a world where Disney
stories should have a lesson it's a
great lesson a great example of
perspective we see it as a kitchen we
see it as Food Network Sebastian would
see it as a House of Horrors they cut it
out Disney Live Action you know they
play it safer than the animations did
maybe they felt like well we made all
the marine life look real so now it
looks like we're we're killing them
we're killing their people but I mean it
shows Scuttle in the movie eats a fish
no one cares flounders like Scuttle you
eat my people
we're still friends I guess I don't care
so you know it's weird a little
inconsistent there all right so the
Little Mermaid have you seen it what did
you think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]